my name is martin schlumberger
i have been in kyogen working on product
development for almost 19 years
and among the products that with my team
i've been responsible for developing
is the rn easy ffpe kit rna
isolation on the kaya symphony and i've
also been involved with the
all prep dna rna ffpe kit
the topic of this webinar is isolation
of
dna and rna from ffpe tissue
key considerations important aspects
and also how to isolate both analytes
from the same tissue section before i
start with the actual webinar i
have to point out that the products that
are shown here or mentioned are intended
for
molecular biology applications and not
for actual diagnosis treatment or
prevention of disease
for successful isolation of nucleic
acids from ffpe samples
there are three essential steps that
need to be included and the first one
is the paraffinization to
make actually make the tissue
accessible for further treatment with
various aqueous solutions enzymes and
such
and for the paraffinization um
traditionally hydrophobic solvents such
as xylene or limonene have been used
and more recently kyogen has
developed the paraffinization solution
that
makes the whole process more efficient
and
faster for example you don't need to dry
your
tissue sections after the
paraffinization anymore
the second step is to solubilize the
nucleic acids
and the best way to do that is usually
a digestion of cross-linked proteins
using protein ace k
or other progenesis and what is
important to realize here is
that the proteinases
usually digest especially also crosslink
proteins not
down to individual amino acids but
rather leave behind
short oligopeptides that
then at one point are still cross-linked
to the nucleic acid and thereby
prevent enzymatic conversion like
cdna synthesis or pcr the experience is
that
dna actually requires a much longer
protein sk
treatment or proteinase treatment in
general than rna
and a possible explanation for that is
the tight association of dna with
histone so there is
probably a lot more cross-linked protein
than
in case of rna and then the third steps
because we still have
the protein residues cross-linked to the
nucleic acid after the proteinase
treatment
we need some way of removing those or
getting rid of
as much or as many of those as possible
to make
the nucleic acid a good substrate for
enzymatic reactions
and this is usually done by heat
treatment in optimized buffers that
helps chemically
breaking these crosslinks
and for that step also
there is a difference between dna and
rna in that
dna requires a harsher treatment
than rna and at the same time the dna
can also tolerate a harsher treatment
whereas
rna you have to be more careful
that if the temperature is too high or
the treatment too long it may cause
additional fragmentation of the nucleic
acid i will now
go through each of these important steps
and provide some data to illustrate
important aspects and what we consider
best
starting with the paraffinization
so there are certain protocols where the
paraffinization is done by
simple melting of the paraffin in lysis
buffer
and here in this uh experiment this is
compared
to the paraffinization using our uh
departurization
solution this is done in k here for dna
extraction
and dna yield has been determined
by uv-vis-based quantitation like a
nano-drop
and also using a fluorescent dye based
essay
what you can see immediately is that
uv this od measurement tends to
overestimate
yields quite a bit this is something
that we are seeing
uh systematically and particularly in
case of ffpe
samples so you need to be careful
uh and mindful of what the methods you
use
and how it compares to other methods
and what you can also see that for both
methods
we're getting quite a bit higher yields
if we use the departurization solution
to really separate
the paraffin efficiently
compared to just melting
and we also did qpcr here
for um the amplicon is a
short piece of ribosomal dna from the
18s
gene um and what you can see
basically the pcr results confirms uh
the
quantitation the physical quantitation
in that we see quite a bit lower
ct values when we use the
paraffinization solution
here we are looking at isolubilization
of rna from ffpe sections
and what is the actual time required for
efficient solubilization of the rna
specifically
and what you can see here so the time
frame or the digestion times used here
there from 15 minutes
up to 24 hours of protein sk digestion
the small picture here shows that
in a lot of cases you need more than
three hours for
complete digestion of pieces of tissue
and for optimal rna
yield you can see that 15 minutes or 24
hours days
in all cases for all of these tissues
there is actually very little difference
indicating that 15 minutes is enough
and you do not need full solubilization
of the tissue
and the same is also con confirmed when
instead of
physical rna yield determination we're
looking at
qpcr we get
there is a lot of variability here which
is typical for
ffpe samples but essentially we're
getting the same ct values after 15
minutes that we get after 24 hours
on the other hand what you can see on
the right
looking at the bioanalyzer electro
ferrograms
that after prolonged protein sk
treatment 24 hours you start actually
seeing a negative effect on
rna integrity so not only are 15 minutes
sufficient it's also better for your rna
quality
based on the observation that rna and
dna
require different times to solubilize
from ffpe
section scientists said kyogen actually
developed a protocol for
isolation of or separate isolation of
dna and rna
from the same ffpe section
without splitting samples or anything
and the way that works is after the
paraffinization a short
protein sk treatment is performed to
solubilize the rna
and then that first lysate is removed
and the remaining tissue is
treated with additional protein sk for a
longer time
so you have a second lysate that then
and and then you can isolate the rna
from the first lysate and the dna from
the second lysate
and importantly this patented method
also allows
to use in the ensuing steps optimal
conditions
for crosslink removal as well so we can
do
a more gentle crosslink removal for the
rna and a much more stringent one for
the dna
with so we get really optimal results
for each of the two analytes
and of course the benefit of getting
both
nucleic acids from the same section is a
big benefit
not only because you get higher yields
than by
splitting the samples in half but you
also get
the analytes from the exact same cell
population so
if you have for example a tissue section
that contains both normal and
tumor cells this will ensure that
the portion of tumor cells that you
isolate
your nucleic acid from is the same
exactly same from
for both analytes here is some data
showing why the crosslink removal step
is so crucial for
nucleic acid isolation from ffpe in this
case
for rna isolation on the left you can
see
yields determined by od measurement
for both lung and kidney tissue
and for different first we have
different
times for of pk treatment 15 minutes at
55 degrees
and also 30 minutes and then
for each of these two protein sk
treatment times we
also have additional heat incubation
at 80 degrees for either 10 minutes or
20 minutes
and this is again in a buffer that is
specifically optimized to break
such crosslinks and if you look at the
yields
you can see that at 30 minutes
compared to 15 minutes you get quite a
bit higher
yield especially from kidney and
when you do only the 15 minutes you get
you reach the same yield if you include
the 80 degree incubation on the right
you then can see how this
isolated rna performs in qpcr
and important here is we normalized the
rna input into each sa
to 50 nanogram and
again for the 15 minutes 55 degree
without the actual 80 degree crosslink
removal step
you can see if it doesn't matter if we
do 15 or 30 minutes at 55 degree the ct
values are roughly the same
and when we include the crosslink
removal step then we get a dramatic
improvement of the pcr results the ct
value actually drops
from around 28 to
less than 24. so this is a
huge difference and shows why the
crosslink removal is
really essential here or in general for
all
ffpe centers and the same is true
for dna isolation as well
in this experiment there are different
crosslink removal times and conditions
you can see starting from 30 minutes at
90 degree
up to 30 90 degree 30 minutes or one
hour
and then compared to 70 or 80 degrees
for one hour or for four hours
and also compared to just a prolonged
protein ace k
treatment overnight at 55 or 56 degrees
centigrade
and again on the left is the
a dna quantitation sorry this is dna of
course
and you can see the highest yield
we get with the one hour at 90 degree
and with the prolonged
incubation at 56 degree we can in some
cases get almost as good
dna in other cases not so there is a lot
more variability
but what is important when you look
again at the qpcr results
on the right and again here the dna
input is normalized
you can see that in this case the
56 degree incubation is not
good enough even if you do it overnight
and the best results really by far
are those obtained after one hour at 90
degrees
and almo pretty much the same at
four hours for four hours at 80 degrees
but anything less than that lower
temperatures or shorter incubation times
lead to poor performance in pcr
and in this case for both
long and a short amplicon 66 and 500
base pairs
again from the 18s ribosomal dna
gene another important complication
from ffpe samples is that
the formaldehyde fixation and storage
can result in deamination of cytosines
and this would eventually
result in artificial c2t transitions
that can then show up as false
false positives or false variant
especially when you do sequencing
of of these dna molecules
and to exclude those artificial
mutations from from your analysis the
best way is really to do a
ung treatment uracil and glycosylase
this will cut out the
deaminated cytosine so the aminated
cytosine is uracil
and the enzyme removes that and so those
affected dna strands are not included in
your sequencing reactions and will not
give
false false mutations at the end
so you can see that on the left the
number of mutations
that are present at very low frequencies
and you can see that the ung treatment
removes those mutations
and then those mutations that are
reported that the higher frequency the
true mutations
they are maintained and um
this you can see on the right here these
are uh
the mutations the true mutations and
those
are not affected by by the enzymatic
treatment
we're now moving to quality control of
the isolated nucleic acids
and for dna one aspect
that people are looking at is the
integrity or
physical length of the isolated dna
and here you can see two examples from
actually kyogen kit used for
dna isolation one is the chiamp dna ffpe
tissue kit
and the other the generate dna ffpe kit
and what you can see easily is that
the generate the dna isolate with the
gene read kit is a little bit shorter
than with the kaya amp kit but so you
would normally say
that the dna quality is maybe worse
but in reality when you look at pcr
performance
here again two different uh length
amplicons from the
uh human prion protein gene 78
and 465 base pair amplicon lengths
respectively
you can see that actually the generate
the dna isolated using the generate kit
gives a
better ct value even so the
dna looks less intact on the gel
and uh so that is true for qpcr
the that the integrity is not really
a main indicator in part
because uh short dna often performs
better in qpcr
and also because the physical length of
the dna
does not reflect to what degree the
crosslinks are
actually reversed and with respect to
sequencing
uh since we are looking at a 465 base
per amplicon here
you can also probably uh agree with me
that
this is easily long enough for all the
standard ngs application or library
preparation protocols
so this is not really limiting in any
way
in case of rna integrity is usually
assessed using a capillary
electrophoresis
with instruments like the agilent
bioanalyzer or
the kaya xl from kyogen and those
instruments often provide something like
an rna
integrity number in this case here shown
again for the bioanalyzer
for a different rna
samples here rna was isolated
from red tissue sections either
shortly after fixation and embedding
this is the t0 on the left and
also after 12 months of storage at
either 4 degree
room temperature or 37 degree and what
you can see
immediately is that the rna integrity is
very different for all of these but
it's also different for the room
temperature and 37 degrees
but the rim numbers are actually fairly
close together
so they in our few do not really
uh fully uh represent the quality
difference like in for example for the
brain tissue
after 12 months at room temperature you
can still see
a bit of ribosome of a ribosomal peak
here
and for the 37 degree sample
it's much more degraded but the rin
number is actually not dramatically
different
so in our mind or in our view
for real numbers below like four or so
they do not provide that much
information anymore
or much differentiation and apparently
people at illumina also came to the same
conclusion
so they suggested uh an alternative
parameter for rna integrity
for especially for sequencing which they
called dv200
which i will comment on in the next
slide
dv 200 is quite simply
the portion of the fluorescent signal
that comes from
rna fragments longer than 209 200
nucleotide
versus those from shorter
fragments and the rationality behind
that is obviously that
rna fragments shorter than 200
nucleotides are considered
not very useful as at least for long rna
sequencing
and the purpose of such a measure is to
compare different rna samples with
regard to preservation of
rna integrity and what kind of
sequencing results can be expected
from those what is important
to keep in mind is first
the electropherogram shows the physical
integrity
but it does not reflect the chemical
modification by formaldehyde the
crosslinks that may be remaining or
remnants of the crosslink proteins that
will interfere
with cdna synthesis or pcr amplification
and to include that aspect of nucleic
acid quality
the best way is really to perform qpcr
on decembers
and the other thing that is important to
keep in mind
um that this parameter is
not really suitable to compare different
rna
isolation methods and how well they
preserve rna
integrity because different methods and
protocols
often differ in how well they
isolate short rna fragments so some
methods that do not isolate any rna
below 200 nucleotides will
pretty much always give high dv 200
even if the sample is not great the
yield will be
just drop a lot so that is
important to keep in mind
to summarize that aspect nucleic acid
integrity or length distribution
is important but it also depends on the
downstream application that
the nucleic acid is used in for ngs
based analysis
often you need a minimum length of maybe
200 base pair or longer
whereas for pcr and qpcr short
fragments can still be analyzed and and
also provide really useful information
and in many cases when you have a kit or
protocol
that isolates short fragments like you
see here in the example on the right
this is a pretty old
data piece of data
it's actually quite easy to modify that
protocol
to not recover these short fragments
in case they are really unwanted
and before i conclude i just want to
mention again that
this webinar is part of a series of
webinars about uh various tips and
tricks on
ffpe samples how uh what are the best
uh or what are pre-analytical
considerations
um considerations for nucleic acid
isolation and also for
essays that can be performed on those
and that brings me to the end of the
webinar thank you again for your
attention
and your interest
sample to insight